Speaker 1: Once Donald Trump got indicted and
then arrested as a result of the New York hush
money payment investigation, the consensus among
political wonks became that his approval numbers,
at least among Republicans, would actually go
up. And this is, of course, because Republicans
love claiming to be the victim and they love to
pacify Donald Trump when he plays the victim,
when he goes around the country and acts like,
oh, everyone's just trying to get me and every
investigation into me isn't actually because I
committed any wrongdoing. It's all just part of
a. Craddock hit piece. It's a witch hunt and it's
all very unfair. Despite, of course, Republicans
claiming to be the people who support rule of
law, law and order, personal responsibility,
not acting like a fragile special snowflake. All
these other things, they do make an exception to
these rules when it comes to their dear leader,
Donald Trump. So the prediction was that the
indictment slash arrest news was actually going to
help Donald Trump in the upcoming primary battle.
And it seems like that's actually playing out
because we now have a new poll from Reuters Ipsos,
which shows that Donald Trump is at 58% support in
the Republican primary, with Ron DeSantis all the
way down at 21%. That's 37% down, which is quite
astounding. Now, we know that the Santos tends to
do better in these poll matchups when he is in
a one on one competition against Donald Trump,
since his support doesn't get diluted amongst
these other candidates who don't really have a
chance realistically. But at least as it pertains
to this poll, it doesn't seem to have that much
of an effect, because in this poll poll, we see
Donald Trump at 58%, we see DeSantis at 21%. And
then all the way down at the bottom of the list,
we see Mike Pence at 4%. He probably shouldn't
even bother to run at this point. I don't see what
reason he would want to get in this race for Nikki
Haley is at a pathetic 1%, even though she is
officially running. We have Liz Cheney, who's
at 3%. She may run, but my guess is that if she
does decide to run, it would be as an independent
to sabotage a potential Trump candidacy rather
than to run as a Republican where she'd have no
shot at the at the primary. We have Mike Pompeo,
Vivek Ramaswamy and Glenn Youngkin, who all have
1% support, and then Kristi Noem, Chris Christie,
Tim Scott and Chris Sununu all are at 0%. Now,
this poll is particularly good for Trump. His
58% is up from the same poll that had him at 48%
earlier this month and 44% from the middle of
March. We, of course, can never glean too much
from one poll and we tend to see regression back
to the mean. But it is important to remember that
more charges may soon be coming against Donald
Trump, particularly out of Georgia and maybe even
from Washington, D.C. If that's the case, Donald
Trump may be able to build up on his momentum and
this race could be over before it even starts.
The first primaries aren't until February of
next year, so that's like ten months away from
now and there's plenty of time remaining. But
with the Santos currently so far behind, he may
get scared out of announcing altogether. He may
assess that it's just better for him to wait until
2028 or 2032 if he wants a real shot at winning
this thing. Because at that point, Donald Trump
is not going to be in the picture anymore. And as
long as he can continue to stay relevant in the
world of politics, keep doing what he's doing in
Florida, maybe he'll be able to still be relevant
and run a successful campaign in a future election
cycle. Of course, the Santos seem to have a real
shot at winning this thing following the 2022
primaries when he way outperformed the Trumpian
candidates. But I believe that his star may have
peaked too early, and now it's Donald Trump's turn
once again. We also don't suspect that DeSantis
would do what it takes to take down Trump, which
is to go at him forcefully and directly. He'd
likely be tepid for as long as possible until
he has absolutely no choice but to go after
Donald Trump in desperation once it's already too
late. That's what we saw took place in 2016 in the
Republican primary. I remember Marco Rubio and Ted
Cruz at the very last minute tried to get into the
dirt with Donald Trump, but it was far too late
at that point. They should have tried to do it
earlier if they were going to take down the king
in Republican circles. And if DeSantis decides not
to run, if he announces he is not going to enter
the race, we can just wrap this thing up. Right?
Donald Trump is going to have the nomination
easily in 2024. Spare me if you think that Nikki
Haley or Mike Pompeo or Asa Hutchinson is going
to be able to put a stop to that. And of course,
Republicans are only shooting themselves in the
foot by doing this, by choosing Trump, since
Trump does not match up very well against Biden
or any other Democrat in the general election,
DeSantis does a lot better than Trump does against
a Democrat in the general election, and Trump is
going to have the stench of criminality now on him
that he didn't necessarily have in prior election
cycles. Plus, there's these other things that he
has to worry about, like the Capitol insurrection.
This will be the first time that Trump is on
the ballot since January six, 2021. So that's
probably not going to play well amongst general
election voters. So there's this real Stockholm
syndrome going on within the Republican Party
where even if other Republican figures and right
wing voters know that he's bad for the party, he
lost them elections in 2018 and 2020 and 2022,
and he's probably poised to do it again in
2024. Even though they know all that stuff,
everyone's still too afraid to cross him. And
I guess they just love his personality so much
that they'll be willing to support him even
when the evidence shows that he is a loser
and he's only hurting the party. So that's the
latest on the polling. Trump seems to be running
away with this thing at the moment, and we'll
see if Ron DeSantis even decides to get into
this race because it's. Not looking so good for
him at the moment. All right. We're going to go
to a break right now. We'll be back with much
more of the David Pakman show right after this.